Hey everyone.
It's Bill Burr,
the affable host of the Monday morning podcast.
Before we get started with this week's wonderful episode,
I wanted to take time out to talk about my new comedy network that I started
with the wonderful Al Madrigal,
um,
name of the websites,
all things comedy,
uh,
go to all things,
comedy.com.
It's our own podcast page.
We have what we like to think is the best collection of podcasts out there.
And it's growing by the day we got my Monday morning podcast,
we got the a skeptic tank with Ari Shaffir Harlan highway,
the long shot walking the room.
Jake Johansen's,
Jake this minivan,
men with Al Madrigal,
the flop house.
Your mom's house.
Saw a deep shit with baron Vaughn and the laugh spin podcast.
And this week we are proud to,
to be adding the Tom Rhodes podcasts and Jackie Cassian's Dork forest.
And we got some more coming up.
Um,
and this week I wanted to highlight a couple of my buddies things.
free tickets to Al madrigals comedy central hour taping an Austin,
Texas,
Thursday,
October 25th.
That's right.
Free tickets at the Moody Theater tickets go are going quick.
So if you're in the Austin,
jump on these now,
just look@thetopofthepageonalmadrigal.com.
Click on the link and you're in the show.
And,
uh,
personally I endorse Alma at Madrigal a hundred percent,
totally original,
absolutely hilarious.
He's one of my favorite comics.
And,
uh,
when I first moved out here to la,
he was one of the first guys I saw and I was,
I was like,
thank God.
Here's a guy can watch every night.
So please go and watch him.
And I'm like,
I said,
cds by Ari Shaffir and Tom Segura and my new book cheat,
a man's guide to infidelity.
That's it.
Please go to all things,
comedy.com listen to my podcast and everybody else's and uh,
go on there.
Explore.
Have a good time.
Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 15th,
2012,
20 to 12 days.
Um,
this is soulful October.
Make sure to wear your fake pink Afros for,
to raise soul awareness in October.
I want to fucking have some sort of counter uh,
awareness thing to try to dip into all this pink.
All this pink that I'm seeing out there.
It's like I got it.
I was aware of it before the month.
Okay.
Stop jamming it down my throat there.
You know,
we already got a month of it in the NFL breath cancer or we're raising
awareness.
Why don't you raise money to cure it?
Okay.
Isn't that what you're supposed to be doing?
If you raising awareness,
what exactly does that mean?
They said that on my flight I was on a Delta flight,
you know,
went to the airport and I'm once
again,
come fly with me,
you red face fucking cons and I'm flying
from New York City to Los Honga lays,
right?
And I get on the flight and I'm looking at the ladies,
The stewardesses,
and they're sitting there in jeans and a pink shirts.
And I was like,
oh
right,
here we go again.
Here we go again.
All right.
So we sit down and they get on the floor.
You know,
they get on the fucking horn there and they go,
thank you for flying delta.
If you could step out of the aisle to help expedite fucking word,
I can't stand.
That word does not exist other than in the fucking corporate world.
All right.
To expedite the boarding process,
we'd like to have an on time departure
rich.
That's not on me.
That's on you.
Okay.
You said the shit was leaving at fucking 10 past 11.
I didn't.
Why don't you start boarding the fucking thing earlier or at least give us a
little one room back here.
So anyways,
of course,
once we get the plane starts going,
she goes,
I'm the captain is still has the seatbelt signs on.
You cannot use anything electronically.
Here's my memorized joke that I say everything flight about electronic stuff.
And then she goes,
so you might've noticed,
um,
the flight attendants are not wearing our usual uniforms.
Yes.
Really?
We're actually wearing jeans and pink shirts to raise breath cancer awareness.
If you'd like to buy a ham sandwich that was put together by a Filipino child
nine weeks ago out in the French Riviera sweatshops section of Nice,
a portion of the proceeds will be going towards raising breath cancer awareness.
They keep saying that shit raising breast cancer awareness,
shouldn't they be raising money to cure it?
You know,
I think the awareness is out there.
So if you're just raising money,
if I go and buy that fucking cool Bano fucking,
you know,
ham and cheese with the pickles,
their sandwich,
right.
I'm buying it thinking that I'm going to help the fucking disease.
It might if you're just doing it to raise breast cancer awareness for that.
Am I just giving you money to buy more pink shit?
Is that what I'm doing?
That's what I want to know.
What a,
what am I buying this sandwich for?
You know,
it's funny,
you know God damn well this,
somebody within that fucking pink organization is pulling down high six figures
for raising breast cancer awareness.
You know they are.
There is somebody right now down at some fucking dealership going,
do I buy that overpriced shiny motherfucker or this one?
Alright with fucking,
he's got pink fucking twenties in his pocket.
Can appeal them off like Kanye West.
Right?
Um,
Kanye West,
stop a Dee da Ba ba ba Ba ba Ba.
That's my impersonation of his rapping style cause he thinks his crowds are like
borderline retarded and they don't understand words.
So he has to slow down every third one.
I'm not saying no,
go no fuck a day.
But then,
oh they should rebreak his jar cause he's still looks like a fucking pug.
Um,
oh,
I'm in a mood.
Why in such a country mood bill?
I'll tell you why.
Because I have a 14 hour flight today to fucking Australia and I didn't want to
think about that.
But let's get back to the pink shit.
You know,
one of the classic things that,
uh,
football fans will say,
there'll be like,
well why don't they have,
why don't they have prostate awareness month where they were like Brown stuff?
Uh Huh.
You know why they don't have prostate,
um,
awareness month,
aside from the fact that guys couldn't organize a fucking fishing trip without
drinking a 12 pack first.
Um,
it's because guys are already watching NFL football.
That's why we're already watching.
There's no way to,
there's no reason.
There's no,
what's the upside
of that?
Reminding us that are asked might fall out someday while we're watching the
fucking overrated Seahawks.
Oh,
I'm going to get to that,
by the way.
I'm going to get to that.
All right.
You've tree hugging fucking Kurt Cobain,
candle lit vigil fucking Douche bags.
I'm going to,
you know,
I'm going to get to you guys right fucking now.
I am so sick of them talking about how fucking,
well before I do that,
let's,
let's be honest here.
The Patriots did not deserve to win that game.
Tom Brady had a horrible fucking game.
Um,
and our defensive backs just,
I don't know what they're doing.
Can Somebody for the love of God explained to me what the defensive backs on the
New England patriots are doing?
Are they covering the receivers or they just merely giving them an escort down
the field.
We made that fucking rookie look like God Damn Joe Montana,
the amount of fucking jump balls that guy through just through a jump ball,
then the general vicinity and our guys are just running down the field.
Of course with these new fucking uh,
rules.
And this goes on,
on,
on both sides.
The,
the,
the rules in the NFL are just fucking horrific at this point.
Do you see that jets game?
Look,
Andrew luck throws a pic commodities running it into the end zone.
Let's come on over to,
you know,
to try to cause some sort of traffic.
So he goes out of bounds.
It doesn't score.
And guess what?
He gets blocked any falls on his ass and call a penalty roughing the
quarterback.
Okay.
I'm adjunct.
I don't,
I don't get it.
I don't know.
There's one of the worst fucking calls I've ever seen in my life other than,
than that fucking call against the Yankees at second base.
Now that,
that,
that right there was,
um,
I would investigate that on party.
Did you have like,
did you have money on that fucking game?
Whatever,
whatever,
whatever.
So that's bullshit.
That whole,
the whole protecting of the fucking quarterback is such horseshit.
There was one play,
the Patriots,
one of our linebackers came in,
right?
Seattle's quarterback is in the follow through with throwing the ball.
He goes to swat the ball.
The ball goes by,
he misses it and part of his forearm,
I mean hit the guy's head.
And I mean not even hard.
He swatting at the ball,
they call roughing the passer.
And that was yet another jump ball that he threw.
And this is the coverage the Patriot's guy has.
He gives him his little little touch.
You're allowed to touch the receiver when within the first five yards.
But I think at this point you're allowed to do it with only two fingers.
You know,
one didn't index fingers or two pinkies in the thumb.
Okay,
you're allowed cause pinkies a shorter,
you're allowed to touch the fucking receiver.
And then after that you just,
all you can do is run next to them.
This is why if I see one more mediocre fucking jackass throw for 350 fucking
yards,
it's unbelievable.
You,
when I was a kid,
when you played football,
you fucking ran with your guy,
you saw his eyes,
and then you turned around,
you look back at the quarterback and then you hand check the receiver.
You didn't grab his jersey,
you just put your hand back so you knew where the fuck he was.
Okay,
that's it.
You can't even do that.
So all these fucking guys do now is they just run down the field with them and
then when they see their eyes go up at the last second,
they try to turn around and by then it's,
it's,
it's fucking over.
By the time they realize the balls there,
the receivers fucking Dick is in his face and then they just sort of grab around
his waist and pull the guy down and they're like,
oh,
I'm not her,
but Dang for fucking Joe blow,
he has 400 yards passing in the second quarter,
a new NFL record.
It's amazing.
He couldn't carry Dan Marino's fucking jock strap.
But for some reason he just broke one of his records.
Ah,
ah.
I swear to God.
I am.
I'm going to stop fucking watching NFL football.
Okay.
If he can't fucking hit the quarterback and you can't cover the receivers and I
have to watch another fucking guy go 36 for 58 I don't want to see 58 six yard
passes in a game.
I don't want to fucking see it.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Maybe they'll make a helmet that will allow them to play football again and I
want to apologize to all those rugby fucking fans.
I was wrong after really watching it this week and I've been on the road for six
straight weeks up to really sitting down there.
Okay.
Watching the NFL package.
Dude,
I don't even recognize the fucking game anymore.
Do you know somebody what?
My buddy was his back east in Boston.
You see fucking Wes Welker was a tough son of tough son of a bitch.
Did you see him get fucking stock after he made that catch just a fucking great
old school rattle your fillings hit.
It was the shit one of those things where you sit at home,
you see the hit and you're like,
yeah,
right there.
Aside from obviously the speed of the game,
that hit right there is why I'm on the couch watching and not playing because if
that ever happened to me,
I would have fucking,
if I didn't die instantly I would have been crying like a little girl and I
would have crawled off of my forearms and just laid in the fetal position for
the rest of the fucking game as opposed to,
well,
group got up,
was out for one play and came back and count in like another 15.
Yarder um,
just a great fucking hit some fucking sports guy in Boston.
My buddy was telling me,
he said that the,
that the guys should be fine for that hit.
I Dunno,
this is it.
You know what it is,
is the timeout generation is coming of age
and uh,
I don't recognize it,
but I got to tell you a fucking Seattle,
their fans annoy the fuck out of me.
They really do.
I'm so sick of them getting all this fucking credit for being this loud crowd.
The 12th man,
you know,
your 12th man should be,
it's your 12th man every week should be the architect that built that stadium
because they knew you guys were just average fucking fans.
So they had to like design a symphony hall to enhance how loud your chairs are.
I went to that stadium.
You can't fucking believe how loud it is.
You're looking around going,
how is it this loud?
And I'm looking at the expressions on people's faces.
They're not any more intense,
nothing.
It's that fucking overhang.
They built this symphony,
the capture,
every fucking cheer that goes up there.
And now these guys are out there thinking they're like these bad ass fans with
your ugly ass fucking uniforms.
Ah,
and to make matters worse.
Yeah.
And every week they have some fucking B list celebrity go out there and I forget
what he does.
He blows a trumpet or raises a flag.
It was so forgettable.
I was actually at the ads to have have most of this is because I'm mad that my
fucking team blue that Goddamn game.
No,
we didn't even blow.
We fucking didn't even deserve it.
We didn't fucking deserve it.
It's just counting.
Am I not taken away from Seattle?
Seattle totally deserves it.
The fucking defense is great and everything was awesome and I really liked,
I love how fucking big and hard their uh,
their,
their hit and everything was great.
And then this morning I'm watching the NFL network and one of their corners is
on there talking trash,
but he's like giddy.
It was like a,
I had Douche chills going up the arm back down the arm and back up the,
I mean it's just like
no
butch.
Ah,
it was like,
dude,
please stop talking.
You just one,
just sit there like,
it was no big deal.
Why are you trying to act like you're a Badass and you,
you sound giddy.
You want a game and fucking October.
Absolutely get,
he sounded like he shook.
Elvis has hand.
Ah,
you can quote.
We put it on the unit
work.
Oh,
go wash your dreads.
Nobody gives a fuck when one fee wouldn't.
One fucking game.
You went one fucking game in October and you're fucking sitting there
texting about it.
And then Tom Brady said this and then I said that Danny,
right some he said fucking,
she said Horse Shit.
Just be thankful that you have one more fucking victory than you really deserve
because of those replacement refs.
Honestly,
Seattle,
honestly,
do you really think you're going to win the Superbowl this year?
You know,
even with your,
your,
your enhanced acoustics there.
You know who I'm actually,
you know,
it'd be interesting,
um,
who,
who designed that stadium did Paul Simon,
did he have a word in that?
Did he sit there on the 50 yard line?
You know,
singing one of is going to San Francisco songs.
James Taylor,
maybe he said out there.
Okay.
James,
let's just see if we've moved the roof in,
um,
far enough to capture every sound in this building.
I've seen fire and I've seen rain.
I was saying Saturdays.
Oh my God.
Oh it,
most of that.
Most of that was me.
I'm just pissed at my fucking team lost.
Uh,
why won't they let him play football anymore?
Everybody
is it because they're worried about a class action suit with all these fucking
concussions just makes,
make them sign a waiver.
I understand that if I get my head slammed at 40 miles a fucking hour every
three seconds playing this game,
that eventually there might be some sort of physical side effects.
I take on all these personal fucking,
uh,
risks myself and I agreed to go out there and play football the way it was meant
to be played.
Oh.
Oh,
I got to tell you
right now,
the two biggest things ruining the game though.
I mean,
you do it to protect the players,
but the fucking Brady rule,
I'm actually sitting there watching Brady and he's bugging me every time he gets
somebody runs by him too fast,
he looks over at the ref.
It's just like,
you know,
I,
it's,
I'm going to stop,
um,
who,
I'm not going to stop watching.
I'm just gonna keep bitching because I have nothing better to do on a fucking
Sunday.
This is the truth of the matter,
but this fuck do back in the day,
defensive backs,
man,
they had attitude,
man.
They were up on their toes.
He'll write up on the line that got in your face.
They could fucking intimidate you,
but like you can't even play defense.
It's like a chaperone on a fucking prom night.
I don't know.
But even if he could play defense,
I swear to God,
I fucking corners are terrible.
Fucking terrible.
I know I don't get the fucking game,
but you know what?
I can't stand.
I fucking hate zone defense.
Hey,
when you're covering a guy and then you just let them go,
you let them go.
And then that other guy,
and then he has like eight yards before another guy's going to go pick them up
and they lay sitting down in the zone,
sitting down in the zone.
He's not even fucking covered.
All right,
I got my fucking Tampon out.
Let's go.
Let's fucking plow ahead here.
Ah,
I'm going to go up there with a fucking hacksaw one day and I'm gonna cut off
the roof on both sides of those.
Oh,
that fucking stadium.
And uh,
and you know what?
Seattle Seahawks fans,
you're going to find in an embarrassing way how loud you truly are.
Okay?
When an immediately sounds like a Peter Paul and Mary concert.
All right.
Your granola bar or eaten Jack Ass is sitting there acting like you're tough
guys up there.
What do you do?
All your tough guys are out to sea getting the fucking crab legs.
What do you guys do?
Huh?
Sit around and talk about the new world order.
You know,
you such rabid fans,
you lost your basketball team.
Go fuck yourselves.
Um,
let's try neon green.
Ah,
Jesus.
Hey,
did you guys hear there's a new strand of gonorrhea out there is a nice segue.
Airborne gonorrhea.
I really need an echo for that air board board board got herea Maria,
Maria,
Maria
airborne fucking gonorrhea.
Can you believe that shit?
Just when you thought it was safe to take your dick out.
Right here comes airborne gonorrhea and we have evidently San Diego State
University to thank for it.
All right,
so there's a mysterious case of this kid,
right?
He's never gotten laid in his life.
He's kissed a couple of girls,
but that's it.
And somehow he ends up with fucking gonorrhea.
Um,
so the doctors can't figure it out.
Let's pick it up here.
One question about any physical contact or possible mixing of fluids.
The dude responded,
well,
I did sort of brush up against this pretty girl's arm,
but I don't think she noticed that this kid,
as far as they're explaining,
is basically a virgin said after explaining his situation to the doctors at Uc
SDS,
student health clinic,
uh,
blah,
research began examining the peculiar case.
Okay.
Um,
this fucking egg head was the first guy to suspect the fucking thing.
Uh,
a new strand of the disease sometimes.
Well,
here's what he says.
Sometimes when a bacterial disease is present in extremely high quantities
within a relatively small location,
read San Diego State University campus,
they can mutate and in some cases become airborne.
As it turns out,
this was the case at San Diego State University and there's,
virgin just happened to be the first victim.
That's how filthy these fucking kids are down there.
Okay?
Jesus Christ.
They must be going to class barefoot.
Bunch of fucking animals down there.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
Some chick who accompanied the virgin to San Diego state said,
yeah,
it really sucks that the dude who drove us gut gonorrhea,
I mean he didn't even get any ass.
This is a woman saying this and still now look at them.
That really blows.
Wow.
Well there you go.
So there you go.
If anybody has a daughter and you're thinking about where not to send her,
I would not send her to San Diego State University.
Why?
Because of the,
the curriculum is that he said the curriculum,
the,
the safety issues on campus.
Know what?
Well,
well,
what is the reason?
It's because of air board board board got our Maria Maria,
Maria,
Maria
airborne gonorrhea.
That is just fucking insane.
San Diego state gives you wings that gives gonorrhea rings.
They're like the fucking red bull of STDs.
That is fucking shame on you.
San Diego State University.
What are you guys doing down there?
I can tell you what you're not doing.
Okay,
good.
Fucking Lord.
Get it.
Do you know what?
They're going to invent a new condom.
You know that just you,
you're going to put it on like a fucking bathing suit and it's just going to
cover everything.
It'll be like a,
a speedo condom,
you know,
but it's,
but it's very flexible so you're still able to have some sort of sex.
It's just always see this shit this over.
This is nature man.
Nature knows there's just too many of us and she's
just,
I don't know what she's doing.
Okay.
She needs to step up our game though.
Cause if you think fucking airborne gonorrhea is going to stop us.
Okay,
I got it.
I got,
I got news for you,
lady.
I don't,
I don't think it is.
You know,
I realize I am 22 minutes in.
I always fucking do this and I forget to do the Goddamn ads.
By the way.
Congratulations to sandy asch Seattle,
you know,
you know I'm fucking with you.
I'm just fucking pissed that we lost.
All right.
Before you send me all your fucking,
you know,
I did an episode of inside the NFL this week and at the end of the end of it,
I'm standing there with Phil Sims and Chris Collins worth,
who are two of the funniest dudes ever.
Such a great experience doing that show.
So they have me picking games.
So I'm standing there with a guy,
you know,
two guys who both played and super bowls.
Okay.
And I'm just some more on from the stance.
So I'm not really going to sit here and give my pics.
I'm just going to act like an idiot.
So I predicted the Patriots have win by 40.
I said the Texans wouldn't win cause I didn't like their quarterback's face.
I was going to pick Tampa and then set out of,
they got a pirate ship in this stadium.
You know,
they're not taking it seriously.
I just did stuff like that.
The amount of people who took it seriously,
like you thought they were going to win by 40 epic fail.
It's like,
do you,
do you really think I thought they were going to win by 40.
Unreal.
Um,
Jim Florentine,
my Paul Versey doing Jim Florentine.
You got to listen to Paul versus these podcasts by the way.
Uh,
the,
uh,
I think it's the,
the effect.
I can't remember what the hell he calls it.
All I know is that Robinson can is o for 26 in his last 26 at bats.
He just,
he just set a new play off record.
Nobody in the history of the game has gone.
Oh,
Oh for 26.
You know what his verse he save or was he just ah,
you know,
he's just in a slump each.
I got to talk Yankee.
So here in a second.
Hold on.
Here we go.
Let's,
let's do some,
let's do some reads here man.
Um,
okay.
All right.
What do I got here?
Uh,
all right.
Mortgage rates just hit an all time historic low 3.125% APR annual percentage
rate.
For those of you at home keeping score,
I'm sure you're looking for some extra cash for the holiday season or just want
to take advantage of these rates.
Lending tree can help you save hundreds a month.
Can I tell you something?
If you want to buy a house,
3.125 is a great thing to do.
If you're so broke,
you need to take out a second mortgage to buy Christmas gifts.
Uh,
I don't think that's a good idea.
Extra cash for Christmas.
Why would you do that?
Oh,
this is probably the last week they advertise.
Um,
don't do that.
Okay.
You're going to go buy a bunch of Christmas gifts and not have a roof over your
head for God's sakes,
man.
Let's think this through anyways.
It's easy.
It's free and you can feel confident in the lender you choose.
Go to lending tree.com and complete one easy form that takes less than five
minutes to do.
This is basically like,
you know when you're going into like,
uh,
maybe going to go down to San Diego and avoid San Diego State University campus
and you want to find a cheap hotel.
What does it like orbits?
This is like the orbits of,
of mortgages.
You just pump in,
you know what you're looking for,
all your information and they will scan all these different banks.
At your fingertips and you will get the lowest rate,
but please do not take out a second mortgage.
Or they're not saying that.
They just saying,
if you just want some cash
for Christmas,
you know,
I think at that point you got to go chop down a tree and just make a wooden
train for somebody and do the best you can.
That's what I would do.
Um,
a couple of IOU slips.
All right,
plowing ahead.
Uh,
Bill,
uh,
anyways,
you will be able to compare offers from up to four lenders in a few.
Enter the code bur bur are,
you will receive a free mortgage guide,
um,
and then you go 3.1,
two five percentage rate.
That's,
that's unbelief.
I have a nice percentage rate in my house.
All right?
I thought I had a good and all of a sudden look at these guys.
It's even lower and I know what you're thinking.
Well,
why don't you refinance bill?
I'll tell you why.
Because after all the rigmarole,
it's gonna end up costing me more money.
So I'm locked into my rate.
All right?
If you want to get locked into a better rate right now,
now's the time.
Get Yourself,
you know what's great about a house?
If you just pay that thing down,
you know when the apocalypse comes,
you on your thing,
you own your little hut is everybody else is getting thrown out by the bankers
aren't Har Har coming down the street like the penguin and the old Batman
movies.
Um,
he knows getting hope.
If you're going to pay for 30 years to have the one of the low,
the all time historic low interest rate.
There you go.
All right though.
We got it.
Um,
and then of course the classic stamps.com.
Do you like going to the post office really?
Well,
what's wrong with you?
Wouldn't it be great if you didn't have to go to the post office?
Because you could do everything that you could do at the post office,
within your own home dwelling or tent city,
um,
that this is the basic,
you can print legal stamps at any hour of the day.
All right?
You get a postage meter.
stamps.com has no hidden fees.
Um Oh.
Unlike a postage meter,
stamps.com has no hidden fees like meter ink charges or reset fees.
No longterm contracts,
no extra hardware to buy or lease.
stamps.com can save you up to 80% compared to a postage meter plus stamps.com
with stamps.com you can do more with the,
with the meter she come on bill.
Let's focused here.
Use Your existing address books,
sending track information to recipients with a click of the button.
The choice is clear.
stamps.com or if offers features at a fraction of the costs.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out any of my DVDs and a,
I absolutely love it.
I love it.
Um,
use,
use my last name,
birth for,
for my special offer.
No risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage.
You just try it.
You're up 55 bucks.
Where in this economy can you do that?
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are our that stamps.com enter burr.
Alright,
back to the podcast.
And once again,
congratulations to the Seattle Seahawks.
I really don't help,
but you don't win a super bowl.
All right.
Before you get all fucking upset.
Actually,
we are that loud.
Back when we,
when we hit the,
uh,
the King Joe Webb and people pay me their heads,
man.
Um,
we,
we're shotgunning granola bars,
man,
the new world on her.
Um,
actually I love,
I love Seattle.
It's a fucking beautiful city.
You know what I mean?
And it's worth sitting there and talking to those broads with the hairy bushes.
Um,
the fucking New York Yankees.
I got to tell you,
I was just in New York City,
New York,
and um,
I got to tell you something,
Joe Gerardi sitting a Rod,
our pinch hitting him in the ninth inning when they're down sitting a $200
million man.
Mike is arguably the ballsiest gutsiest move I've ever seen by not only a
baseball manager.
I'm trying to think of a gutsy or call.
I know saints fans.
Oh,
what about when we did the onside kick?
Not even close,
not even close.
That's just some,
uh,
razzle dazzle.
You just yet.
That's your file.
That under that shit,
this,
this was an unbelievable mood.
It was such an unreal move from,
for those who didn't watch,
and we're under a rock.
The Guy,
a rowel of Bonnie's who looks like,
I don't know what he looks like.
He looks like
an older Freddy Krueger.
He's an old guy,
but at that way,
I'm four years older than him,
so I look even worse.
Guy Hits a home run.
It was like a movie.
It's like Robert Redford and the natural goes into extra innings.
They went in on a walk off home,
run by whole.
None other than Raul Oban,
Jez.
Again,
it was,
I just was unreal and I absolutely hate the Yankees.
And the next day I'm reading the New York Post,
reading about this historic move and I'm smiling reading about a Yankee when
unbelievable.
I actually got into the baseball playoffs a little bit because,
uh,
I kept doing spots.
Um,
all that whole week I was getting ready to do night of too many stars on comedy
central,
which I taped a Saturday night and will air I believe within the week,
raises money for autism.
And uh,
I kept making fun of that name night of too many stars is too many stars.
Then I showed up and saw
who was there and that was pretty impressive.
I'm not going to ruin it,
but,
uh,
I was definitely,
my head was on a swivel,
so half of my childhood walked by.
Um,
anyways,
yeah.
So I would go out and I would run my set and um,
and then I would,
I would at the end of the night,
I'd go to this bar by myself.
I get a whiskey and I would just sit there and I would want what would watch the
end of the Games.
And,
uh,
what did I watch?
I watch all my God,
I watched the fucking,
it's going to say the senators,
the fucking a nationals.
I watched it nationals.
Oh my God,
that fucking collect that debacle.
That was brutal.
That was like the old school red socks.
That was the way the red sox used to loose.
That was brutal.
So my condolences to national fans.
I sat there watching it and not really giving a shit about the series,
but I was like,
oh they've never want to play.
Want to play off series.
Been Baseball since the 1930s I got to watch this cause these fans are going to
go crazy.
Go crazy folks.
They're going to go nuts and just watching that,
just watching it go away.
What the hell are they?
What are they down by?
Four runs now.
What was it?
No,
they scored four runs.
It was seven to five
they one strike away and next thing you know it's nine to seven cardinals.
Oh,
it was brutal.
It was brutal.
I thought too horrific things that in watching Derek Jeter break his ankle and
have to get carried off the field,
that was just,
that was not something that I wanted to see.
Had I known that that was going to happen,
I wouldn't have watched,
you know,
I see Derek Jeter carried off the field.
It was,
it was brutal.
Fucking brutal.
So anyways,
hats off to a Joe Gerardi man,
that was an awesome,
oh,
what a gutsy call to have to walk up to him and be like,
yeah,
listen,
I'm about ready to humiliate you in front of the country for the better of this
team.
And uh,
if this doesn't work out,
you know,
with the way the New York media is,
they might actually question,
uh,
they're going to question whatever the fuck I do.
And he still had the nerve to do it.
Unreal.
Um,
anyways,
here we go.
Hey Bill.
I'm a huge fan and I just wanted to let you know that recently my mother has
been battling cancer while she's in the hospital recovering from surgery.
And my dad brother and I sat down and watched your special,
even though it might have been an hour of the day,
you made us laugh at a time when we all really needed a low.
Why are we why we,
this is like really nice.
We don't do nice things in the podcast.
I truly believe Blah,
blah,
blah.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Okay,
well I'm glad I was able to do that.
I'm glad my total ego trip.
Look at me.
Selfish thing that I do somehow added to your life and I'm sorry to hear about
your mom.
I hope she gets better.
All right now.
Now,
now we're in this place.
Now we're in this place.
This happened to me on that night of too many stars.
I'm not going to say what happened,
but I had to go on after something that really should have just ended the show
because it was unreal.
It was unreal and I was literally standing there going,
I have to go on after this.
Why,
why?
You know,
gcs,
but the host took me up,
host,
got him back,
got him back to have more sillier place.
Um,
anyways,
the house,
John Stewart,
um,
solid guy,
stand up,
comedian saw the situation.
All right.
Took the bullet for me.
Brought me out.
Nice solid guy.
All right.
Facebook comments.
Bill,
how does someone who can hardly read write a book?
You know how I can do that,
sir?
Um,
I didn't write a book.
I wrote it with two of my friends.
We all held each other.
You know,
they brought me across the finish line,
like Kellen Winslow in that game against the dolphins.
Um,
that's actually not true.
Me and Bobby carried Joe to Rosa across the finish line.
And you know,
not because Joe's not a piece of shit.
Joe Joe is just such a commitment.
Phobe he's never really interrelationship,
so he didn't have that many cheating stories.
Um,
but anyways,
I want to thank everybody who's going out and buying the book.
The book has been doing phenomenally phenomenon.
Pop Baba Baba on,
um,
whatever the hell is the book charts.
So if you haven't got your,
your copy of cheat a man's guide to infidelity,
absolutely hilarious over the top look,
add a men's behavior in the dumb things that we do.
Um,
we got a bunch of our knucklehead friends telling stories about cheating on
women and getting caught.
And then the three of us,
me,
Joe and Bobby basically breakdown their cheat stories like NFL game film and try
to say where they went wrong,
where they went right.
And in the back of the book,
the true reason we wrote the book was to hype our short film that we got into
the Tribeca film festival called cheat.
Um,
you get a link to the movie and you can check it out and it's awesome.
So thank you for everybody and also my special you people are all the same as is
still available for download at [inaudible] dot com and if you're having
problems downloading it,
you have totally my empathy because I would screw it up too because I am also
not good at the computer,
the art of computers.
Just make sure when you just in this,
if you have a problem,
all you need to do is in capital letters in the subject line.
This will help me find your email quickly and get you this special as quickly as
possible.
Just write standup special.
And then in the body of your email,
just have your paypal receipt copied and we'll get it right out to you.
Okay.
Because if you just say,
hey,
I bought it.
I couldn't download it.
I have to do the extra thing of going.
Okay,
send me the receipt,
we'll get it to you.
It's an extra step.
All right.
We're trying to expedite the process of you getting the special.
Speaking of special led Zepplin special,
Mr Burb,
tell me you're excited about the new led Zepplin film about their 2007 benefit
concert.
Um,
Jim Florentine,
he talked about it as most recent podcasts and mentioned how bonds those sons
stole the show.
Yeah.
Jason,
I actually talked to Florentine,
we'll text about it.
He said was the best concert film he's ever seen.
Um,
and I also heard that the members of the band were,
were,
were ridiculously excited after they saw it.
Um,
so he goes,
so I thought that this might be the best dilemma question for you.
If you could see only one last concert,
would you choose ACDC and Argentina or led Zeppelin with bonds?
Oh,
son.
Ah,
Oh,
I,
uh,
that's,
that's actually an easy one.
I would have to say lead's up on with Bonzo son,
just for the simple fact that I've seen ACDC a bunch of times and I've never
seen led Zeppelin and,
um,
as much as I would love to see ACDC and Argentina,
yeah,
I would,
I would go see separately.
You know what I mean?
Cause I,
I,
I saw some clips of it.
What I liked about how Jason played was,
you could just tell that he wasn't intimidated by the moment.
You know,
that poor guy,
he basically,
he had to follow the greatest drummer of all time.
His Dad,
it'd be like if you were Jordan's son and you play in Hoop,
even if you dunk on somebody,
somebody to go,
yeah,
but your Dad,
your dad would've jumped higher.
He said to deal with that his entire life.
And I just felt the way he was playing,
he didn't give a shit what anybody was going to say.
And he did this great blend of um,
stuff that his dad played on the classic recordings and stuff that I've heard on
the Zeppelin bootlegs.
He kind of blended those perfectly while also just being in the moment himself.
I felt like in thrown in some shit that his interpretations and he,
it was,
it was perfect.
He did the perfect balance of,
of staying true to the original and then adding his own flavor to it without
getting in the way.
It was an absolute masterpiece.
So,
um,
there you go.
Look at that.
After coming out heart,
coming out hard and trash and pink shirts and everybody in Seattle,
look at him coming around here,
given uh,
given fucking props to the Yankees and shit.
Jesus Christ Almighty.
Anyways,
barrel bill,
La Beer,
all beer.
Um,
fear of STDs and downgrading.
what's going on,
Bill?
Love the podcast and all the advice you have.
Gail.
You know,
fuck this.
I'm not going to read this right now.
Let's talk about how the F I have to get on a fucking airplane today to fly to
Australia.
All right?
Which is definitely exciting,
exciting new.
Get on board.
What are you going,
Ooh,
your fucking trapped here for fucking 14 goddamn hours.
Okay.
You have two options.
Sit there and take it or do permanent damage to your liver by taking some sleep
aids.
Yeah.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
I'm not into those fucking ambiens and all those types of things because I do
enough damage to my liver with fucking whiskey and all that type of shit I don't
need,
I don't need to be adding to it.
You know what I mean?
You know,
like when the ref gets knocked down in a wrestling match.
And then in the hero guy with the blonde,
blonde fucking mullet is over in the bad guys
corner.
And the guy who's not supposed to be in has got his foot on his fucking throws.
The other guy kicks him in the head,
allegedly.
Yeah.
I don't want to be doing that.
I fucking liver.
So actually tweeted this out.
These are,
these are basically my options for 14 hour flight.
14 fucking hours.
14 fucking out.
What do we,
what are we going by ship here?
Huh?
What,
what are we doing here?
Um,
all right,
first option,
I watch all three godfather's plus Goodfellas and then I try and sleep for six
hours.
That'll be 14 hours or
I,
uh,
take a fistful of Ambien and I watch raising Arizona
and then I'm there.
But I,
I've done this flight before and I did it out of New York City and I flew with
this lady and she took some of those drugs and I kept looking over jealous is
she just slept hour after hour after hour.
And I was sitting there fucking playing tetris for like fuck it,
eight hours.
Um,
um,
what,
but at the end of the flight when,
when she went to get off,
I swear to God,
she looked like she got the shit kicked out of her,
but for some reason her face had,
didn't have the bruises,
but it was all puffy.
She looked horrible.
And uh,
I don't want to do that shit,
so I think I'm going to go with the fucking,
yeah.
But my laptop's going to run out of battery life.
Debbie,
tell you guys how I don't like that movie casino.
It's just too fucking violent.
I love all the other stuff in it.
But that shit with a guy's eye gets popped out or where they make,
and Peshy watched them beat his brother to death with the bat and they're like
burying him while he's still fucking half conscious.
It's just,
it just,
it's just too much.
Just fucking rub me the wrong way.
Those fake deaths I couldn't handle.
Um,
fuck.
So what am I going to do?
I'm taking the lovely kneel with me.
Of course.
Of course she wants to go.
She never goes when I need her.
Like what?
I'm going to fucking,
you know,
some God forsaken place.
You know,
if I'm going some place fun.
Oh,
she's right there on my hip.
You not ladies do that.
Oh,
I want to go.
Sounds like fun.
Oh yeah.
How come Jacksonville doesn't sound like fun.
What about Cincinnati?
Don't think you need to have some fun there.
That's the great thing about this trip is I had fun and all those places.
I had an unbelievably great time in Jacksonville.
Shoot.
And Eaton gator going to the game and then I went up to fucking Cincinnati and I
hate their fucking ribs.
I took a river boat over to the game.
I had a great,
I had a great time.
I really did.
Um,
oh,
and speaking of a great time,
and this is totally just free advertisement.
There's a new standup comedy club in New York City.
There's a new girl in town and she's feeling good.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
What was that?
That was,
there was Alice.
I didn't always knew that there's a new girl in town.
And she's feeling good.
Got a divorce and a big tooth kid and we're going to Arizona
because I'm going to 10 up my mill titties.
I forget how it goes.
Anyways,
that dude was a cute kid.
And then once he fucking,
he once he grew up,
wow.
He went through his fucking awkward years.
All of a sudden he had giant fucking teeth and I didn't look so good.
Tommy.
Tommy was his name.
Um,
the fuck am I talking about?
Why did I just start singing?
Oh,
a new standup club.
The guys who run the club right now,
we're fucking sitting on the edge of their seats.
Go in,
there's this fucking ADT add douche bag actually going to get to it.
And yes I am.
And there's a new new new comedy club.
It's called the stand.
It's on third avenue between 19th and 20th Street and um,
has unbelievable food and there's a great comedy room downstairs.
And I hung out there all fucking weekend,
all week building up for the night of too many stars and a,
I had an awesome time and that's definitely going to be a regular stop for me
when I come back to New York and it's fucking great.
It's great place to take a broad,
they got good food,
great comedy downstairs.
And um,
yeah,
it's kind of the same setup as the,
uh,
the comedy cellar,
you know,
restaurant upstairs,
comedy room downstairs,
you know,
to like a smaller version of that.
So we either are,
there you go.
The comedy cellar,
the classic,
the film,
more of standup comedy clubs in New York City.
And now there's another new one that Stan,
you know,
I actually went around and I did all the old ones.
Man,
I had a great time going back there.
I did,
uh,
did a spot at danger fields,
did a couple of spots at the comic strip.
I went over to a standup New York and went down to the Salah.
It was great.
It was fucking great time.
And then I really actually missed being able to do like four spots in a night
working on stuff.
Um,
that was a great time when my life,
way back in the day,
late nineties,
early two thousands when I was,
when I was living with fucking Bobby Kelly and we would go out and do like eight
shows on a Friday,
eight shows on Saturday.
Fucking end of the night sitting there,
y'all sweaty with fucking 50 bucks,
50 bucks a spot,
whether that'd be 400 bucks.
I've told these stories and I always had to take cabs cause I played downtown
and uptown and Bobby played,
he played the Boston,
the won the seller.
And some nights he do three of each and he'd have nine and he didn't have to
take one fucking cab and he had all his money and I'd be jealous.
Anyways,
fear of STDs and downgrading what's going on.
Bill.
Uh,
I love the podcast and all the advice you've given no matter how a name.
So I thought I'd asked for some advice for myself.
Uh,
for the last year and a half,
I've been tormented by my ex girlfriend.
She dumped me and did the whole,
I want you back thing on and off for a year and a half.
Oh my God,
Dude.
Which is longer than that.
We were together in parentheses only a year.
I don't want to be with,
I don't want to be with her because I now know how much of a cunt she is.
But the problem is that I've been lured into this shit for that period of time.
You've learned to watch shit back into relationship
is he says,
even though during that time we were not together,
I didn't sleep with or do anything with any other girl to make me look like the
bigger person in the situation.
She had a boyfriend during this time because again,
she's a [inaudible]
cunt.
Um,
well dude,
you're a PSAP.
All right.
You get it.
If you're just going to say she's a commentary like you're,
you're,
you're turning the keys over to the right of the whole fucking relationship to
her.
That the reason why this isn't working is because she's a con.
She,
she is a current and you're allowing her cunt and missed to fucking come into
your atmosphere.
Sorry,
I ran out of shit there.
Um,
yeah.
She's like airborne gonorrhea.
Get away from her.
All right.
Anyways,
he goes,
so I haven't had sex in over a year and a half,
which is slowly killing me on the inside.
Do what the fuck is wrong with you?
Don't you have any friends?
Have you told your guy friends that
Ah,
come on man,
you're better than this.
He says in the prospects aren't looking too good.
Not many attractive ladies at my school and the ones who are attractive.
I probably rather date since I'm more of a relation and
ship guy.
Um,
I've never had a one night stand before and would not know how to handle a
situation just approaching girl and getting her to have sex with me within a
couple of hours.
It's not like I don't want to have random sex,
but I am warry of STDs and didn't want to,
don't want to just bang some ugly,
not too attractive.
Broad.
Since my ex was extremely attractive,
I do not want to downgrade in any sense.
Well,
you don't,
you don't have to bang some pig,
dude.
You just need to go out.
This is what you need to do.
You need to go out.
First thing you need to do is go down to the thrift shop and get yourself a
fucking smoking jacket and some slippers.
All right?
And just start fucking walking around and just feeling that vibe.
You have to stop giving a fuck.
All right?
Get yourself a bunch of condoms.
You know,
that's a great thing to do.
Get yourself a bunch of condoms,
like you're preparing for something wonderful to happen and then just get out
there in the game.
Don't care if we don't go out there,
go like,
I have to convince this girl to have sex with me tonight.
You know,
that's you.
You're going to come off desperate.
Just go out there and just fucking have a good time.
I'm telling you right?
And it's like doing stand.
Half of doing standup is if you're up there having the fucking time in your
life,
the crowd's going to go along with you.
They like it,
they see you having fun.
It's contagious.
They want to be around you.
You just go out,
have a good time at a fucking party,
crack some jokes.
Say what's up,
be friendly.
Don't freak them out.
Then eventually he's all,
what's your deal?
What's going on with you?
And they did a little touch on your arm right there.
You're at least rounded second,
you know,
let's do it.
Baby
steps hit a double first before you worry about fucking hitting the cycle.
Um,
that would be my advice to you,
even though I haven't read the rest,
so I don't even know what you're fucking question is.
So let's,
let's plow ahead.
Although now I've also brought up airborne born Ghana,
Rio,
get a gas mask and some condoms and I think you ought to be good.
That's going to be sexier in the next couple of years.
Zach,
right back.
Hi.
Yeah,
it's like my dad.
My Dad.
Yes.
Dan is a
fucking idiot.
Okay.
Oh,
has it?
how are you going to fuck a labor?
You got
your fucking
pitch
that's going to be sex in a couple of a couple of years.
Is that going to be a campaign issue in the next few years?
That'll be tough for on healthcare.
We're going to get schooled deck and we're going to tackle the problem head on
of airborne gonorrhea.
Um,
let's go,
let's get to this fucking question here.
Uh,
I'm also on a college budget and definitely do want to spend extra money I have
on taking some girl out to dinner or some shit.
Well then go fuck yourself dude.
Have Fun jerking off.
You know what?
There's your opening line.
Yeah.
Listen,
I want to fuck you tonight,
but like,
I don't want to waste any money so,
well,
what do you,
what he say?
I'll take it out myself.
You know,
you know,
don't worry,
unless you want to burn some calories,
take it out,
mark.
Um,
so I am wondering if I should stop spending so much time thinking about getting
laid and just focusing on my focus on myself until I graduate and let whatever
happens happens.
Yeah,
that's great.
Should I just take my hand off the wheel and see where the car goes or should I
just say fuck it and try to fuck the next girl who gives me attention?
No,
don't do that.
All right.
You're a relationship guy.
You don't want to go down that fucking road.
Okay.
But also,
you know,
even though you are a relationship guy,
if you're the next one you meet is the one and you get married,
you're going to be,
it's going to bug you.
But you didn't go out and Bang at least fucking 20,
30 girls.
So I would,
you know,
quality sir.
Quality.
Okay.
Make a list.
Check it twice so you don't fuck some whore.
Who's got the Pussy Lice?
Bought up.
Boob up bt Babu.
Um,
all right.
Tattoos.
All right.
I know they're all the fucking rage,
but you know,
that says something about you forget a tattoo.
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
You're definitely on the other side of the skank fence.
Um,
the way a girl dresses,
you want a girl who dresses classy?
All right.
Not like a fucking whore.
She dresses like a whore.
Okay.
A sports car looks like a sports car and it has been driven like one.
You go get a girl who's dressed like a fucking whore.
She has been,
she's been written like one.
You understand the
all the fucking time.
All right,
look,
you know those classic girls can be a lot of fun too.
They really can.
They actually can have a conversation with him.
Your relationship guy,
you know,
you just walk in,
Hey,
what's going on with you?
I'm getting out of the relationship,
you know,
just dated,
this absolute psycho.
She's completely fuck with my head.
I'm not even trying to be in a relationship,
you know,
just hit on with that shit cause I'm actually relationship guy.
Oh he's sensitive.
Maybe we have got a puppy Sunday and you'll fucking be in there
and then,
you know,
I dunno what,
I don't know what you do these day.
You put on some scrill extra dead mouse and you fucking right
bear bear
and then you're fucking cum on her face.
Um,
am I dating a whore?
A bill.
Greetings from Spain.
Oh,
la Mi Amigo.
When are you coming here?
I'm going to come there and watch people get run over by bulls at some point.
And I've realized that the place to be at is you want to be in the arena where
there's nowhere left to run,
you know?
Um,
anyway,
I'm 22 and need some advice about a girl on dating.
She was in class with me in high school.
Dude,
are you bilingual?
And you write this?
What is,
this is fucking amazing.
My old Spanish fell off again cause I can't find the disc to put it on this
fucking laptop.
It's only on my old one.
The worst.
Um,
two months or so ago we met again for my best friend's birthday.
Wait,
let's start over again.
Or he forgot what happened.
She was in class with me in high school.
We were good friends at the time.
Two months ago we met again for my best friend's birthday party.
She fit in my group of friends pretty well.
And after a couple of days we started flirting with each other.
Finally,
one night we hooked up and now we're dating.
Great.
What could go wrong?
Two years ago,
she quit her career in college and I picked another one that she liked
two years ago.
She quit her career in college and I picked another one that she liked.
I don't know what that means.
She had to move to Madrid to attend school.
Uh,
yesterday we were having a small,
small,
small pillow talk and I asked her how many guys she'd bang.
She started counting in my asshole shrunk a little.
It turns out when she was in Madrid,
she fucked six guys in six months and then started a relationship with another
one that went for a year and a half.
Uh,
they broke up a month ago and now she's with me.
So if my math doesn't fail,
counting her first boyfriend,
the six dude that she's fucked in,
this last guy,
I'm dick number nine.
I slept with six women in my entire life.
And somehow I feel like I'm dating a whore that she still in single digits.
You know,
any nine Dicks,
you're number nine eight.
I'm trying to think of the schoolhouse fucking rock song for eight.
Was there one?
Three is a magic number
number.
Nah,
we'll put you on the spot.
Number nine
when a not,
um,
I've slept with six women.
My,
it's so have something six with my entire life in some I feel like I'm dating a
whore.
I can't help but have this horrendous thought in my head.
I'm not a jealous guy at all,
but I caught myself a couple of times and her Facebook page guessing who these
dudes are through.
Don't do that to yourself.
Look,
your competitive.
All right.
You know,
you have six TD passes.
She has nine.
She's going,
she's starting the pro bowl.
Uh,
she's sweet.
She's nice.
She's into me.
But I think it will be different from me to trust this girl,
which had never happened to me before.
I'm feeling miserable.
Any advice will be appreciated.
Yeah.
Dude,
it's not her fault.
You only bank six broad.
All right.
It'd be one thing if she had,
um,
a history of cheating on guys she was in a relationship with,
look,
put it this way,
a woman,
if she's even just halfway decent look and can go out to a bar and get dick
every fucking night.
All right.
Now if you could do that,
if he could turn the fucking table,
if you could go out and get laid like that with women,
how many women women will view of banged
in fucking six months.
180 is what I'm going to say.
Six months.
30 days of fucking month roughly.
Yeah.
You probably would bang.
You'd probably bang 80 before you started thinking,
what am I doing?
And this is empty.
You know,
she banked sex.
Um,
she,
that was probably her fucking little little,
uh,
she got it out of her system.
You know,
she's not fucking around on you.
She's not a horse,
just making ends.
Uh,
uh,
I didn't consider it.
What's the word?
Insecure.
You are right through nine and this day and age with airborne gonorrhea.
I mean,
that's pretty,
that's a pretty fucking low number.
And she did it all in Spain,
way away from San Diego State University,
home of Airborne Kinda Rhea Maria,
Maria,
Maria.
And you think they're going to put that in there?
They're fucking brochure.
You know every,
every college has to be number one in something.
Oh my God.
Who's their big rival in football that you guys got to make the airborne
gonorrhea fucking tee shirts show up with gas masks on for those dirty,
filthy fucking students.
The fact that the fucking chick from the God damn school is sitting there going
in the sad thing,
he didn't even get any ass right there that a fucking lady would talk like that.
Let you know why there's airborne gonorrhea.
Oh,
you fucking skank.
Um,
all right,
eva.
[inaudible] everybody,
if you need help looking for more,
for more proof,
looking more professional or being more efficient,
you should check out he voice.
I personally have received some really great feedback from listeners on Twitter,
um,
that show you guys are really liking he voice and why wouldn't ship I going to
he voice by going to www dot [inaudible] dot com slash bill burr.
You can get a free six month trial of IIE voice.
It helps me as I can now give out multiple numbers that will all come through
one cell phone.
Why do they keep making it me seem like I d I'm not using these products.
I would use it though.
I do endorse it.
If I was trying to start a business,
I would all right,
but I'm not gonna sit here and lie to the listeners,
the listeners.
Um,
you can have virtual answering service with multiple accents that make you sound
bigger than you are.
Transcribe your voicemails to texts or email.
Basically he voice makes your life easier.
It makes a small business owner look much bigger.
My favorite thing is the professional voiceover actors,
actors and actresses that will give you any accent you want and sound all good
looking and stuff and make people want to go to your business.
Go to www dot [inaudible] dot com slash bill burr and you can get,
you can get a free six months trial of iie boys.
Um,
and once again,
lending tree.
If you want to take advantage of the extremely low rates,
3.125% you can act now.
Um,
you can save hundreds and it'll take you just minutes by going to try lending
tree.com.
These rates aren't going to stay like this forever.
Go to try lending tree.com complete one simple form and the network of over 200
lenders will send you for customized loan offers.
You can't do any better than that.
And the last two,
let me just get these out of the way.
amazon.com holiday shopping starting.
Uh,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast and the wounded warriors project,
just go to [inaudible] dot com click on the podcast page,
click on the Amazon banner.
Anything you buy after that on Amazon,
they'll give me a piece.
I kicked the,
uh,
a piece of the piece over to,
the wounded warriors project.
And then you go and that's it.
Um,
okay.
Bill,
what am I doing?
I'm originally from Massachusetts.
I recently got out of the army,
infantry and I'm now living in Hawaii.
They go,
Huh,
that's,
that's a good deal.
He goes,
it's not as good as it sounds.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
there goes all that happiness.
I stayed here because I fell in love with a smoking hot local girl.
She's 29 with three kids,
all from the same guy,
but he's a fucking piece of shit in and out of jail for being,
um,
a meth head like most Hawaiians.
Anyway,
sometimes it feel trapped here playing daddy.
I'm 25 years old.
Ben All over the world,
done my time in the middle of the Terry.
Now I'm going to school to be a firefighter.
Had a fucking college,
were only 6% of the people are white and they fucking hate white people.
How the white people hate white people.
All right.
But it's kind of good deal because her grandfather is a retired federal fire
chief.
So in a year I can be in the firehouse.
I don't know what to do.
She and the kids aren't too bad.
Honestly.
It's all fucking amazing.
But I still feel trapped in this fucking twilight zone fucking life where I've
got three kids and a wife,
air quote.
Another option is,
um,
back in mass drinking beers and trying to avoid getting any felony convictions.
I don't fucking know,
man.
Sometimes I just feel like I'm letting the best years of my life get away from
me.
Then I think maybe these are the best years of my life and I start crying into
my fucking beer.
He got to need advice.
I need a new point of view on this whole thing.
Thanks man.
Jesus,
dude,
this is a fucking dilemma.
You know,
you gave me just enough information to still be
okay.
All right.
Are you going to marry this girl,
the lover like that?
When you're 35,
she's 39 is 65.
She's 69.
You know,
is she going to have any more kids with you?
How many kids do you,
how many more kids
to she want?
You know,
they got fires in Massachusetts too,
you know,
so you can always be a firefighter wherever the fuck you go.
Um,
are you ready for all of this?
This is what you got to ask yourself.
You know,
it sounds like you're pretty happy.
You live in a paradise,
you know,
with those volcanoes there,
you're always going to have work.
There's always going to be some fires,
right.
You know,
when the dollar collapses,
while it's still a zillion people there,
you can still have some shit going on.
Um,
yeah dude,
this is up to you.
Hate to say that.
I mean,
when I was 25 years old,
I was not ready to be living in Hawaii with a woman four years older than me
with three fucking kids.
I was not ready to do that.
Um,
so
I understand why.
If you're feeling shit like that,
I definitely get that.
But I also hadn't traveled the fucking world,
fought in a war and done all,
all this stuff that you've done.
You've lived way more life than I have at 25.
So,
uh,
yeah.
You just got to ask yourself those questions.
What the fuck do you want to do?
You know,
smoking hot local girls,
29,
he's got three kids.
Uh,
you're on the fucking beach.
Once you make friends with Woody Harrelson and get some fucking weed.
I'm sorry dude.
I don't know what to tell you.
This is one,
you know what,
you're gonna have to be on your own in this one.
This is too big a fucking decision.
Too big a decision.
I would just say,
do I love this girl?
Is she the one or am I just here?
Cause she's fucking smoking hot and you know,
doesn't have any tan lines.
That's what I would ask myself.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Um,
tonight I am flying to Sydney,
Australia,
14 fucking hours.
Hopefully there'll be no airborne gonorrhea on the fucking plane.
Um,
ah,
fuck me.
This is going to suck.
But once I land it's going to be awesome.
And um,
I'm going to fuck in a,
I'm going to have great shows out there.
I'm really excited.
I got three nights of shows as far as I know.
I think they're all sold out.
And uh,
so thank you for all the podcasts listeners out there and Sydney for stepping it
up.
And uh,
Oh and also another thing about rugby,
I forgot,
some guy sent me a story,
some guy lost his ball.
And the first half of the rugby game and he played the rest of the fucking way.
So whatever.
All right.
I would put the way the NFL used to be up against rugby.
Now,
um,
my buddy Joe Barton at Kooskia,
who's got a new CD coming out is going to be on hyping a his CD here in a couple
of weeks when he releases it said the funniest thing to me.
He said,
if you want to watch how NFL football used to be,
watch SCC football.
So they go.
So if you're an old fucking NFL head like me,
and you're a little disappointed with the escort that the fucking cornerbacks do
now is a rundown on the field and how you can't block a fucking quarterback
after he just threw a fucking interception and he's basically trying to make a
play.
Uh,
SCC football,
pick a team.
Alabama,
Lsu,
Georgia,
Florida,
South Carolina,
Vanderbilt,
Tennessee,
Arkansas and Mississippi,
Mississippi state.
Who the fuck did I forget?
Kentucky.
Somebody fucking else.
Auburn War Eagle.
We're all fucking great.
Great to watch.
Uh,
that's it.
That's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'm bringing my mixed all the way over to Sydney,
Australia.
Uh,
we're going to have great time out there and a I,
we'll give you some photos and all that type of shit.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Please watch night of too many stars this week on,
um,
on comedy central and thanks to everybody at inside the NFL.
I,
it was a dream come true to be able to do that show.
And I'm for all fans of that show.
Um,
I,
I can't tell you how,
how hilarious everybody was.
It was such a good time.
Just the ball breaking that those guys do.
It's just like you're in a locker room,
you know,
that's all they do is give each other shit.
And when we would be in between segments,
you know,
they would like just egging me on,
give us more shit,
give us more shit.
They would just,
just totally,
just couldn't have been nicer.
Uh,
which ended up being great for me cause I really didn't even feel worthy to be
on the show.
So thank you to those guys.
Um,
and that's it.
That's the podcast.
All right?
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.